astronomie teams haben jetzt ein objekt
in 20 lichtjahren entfernung entdeckt
das weltweit große rätsel aufgibt denn
es ist eine art grenzgänger und steht
genau auf der grenze zwischen stern und
planet es ist deutlich schwerer als der
jupiter aber nur knapp größer zudem hat
es polarlichter und ein äußerst starkes
magnetfeld also wirklich ziemlich
mysteriöse eigenschaften die so
eigentlich nicht zusammenpassen was
steckt hinter dem geheimnisvollen objekt
tricks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
das jetzt entdeckte objekt mit der
bezeichnung spj 01 36 5 663 +0 93 34 73
ist ein wirklich besonderer weise
äußerst mysteriös eigentlich endet es
einen braunen zwerg aber dann doch nicht
in unserer milchstraße könnte es 100
milliarden stück von diesen braunen
zwergen geben sie zeichnen sich dadurch
aus dass sie zu kalt und zu klein sind
um echte sterne mit anhaltender
kernfusion zu werden
auf der anderen seite sind sie aber auch
zu groß und zu warm um als planet
durchgehend zu können oft werden diese
objekte deswegen als gescheiterte sterne
bezeichnet auch in direkter
nachbarschaft zur erde existieren solche
braunen zwerge beispielsweise umkreisen
sich nur 6,6 lichtjahre von uns entfernt
gleich zwei braune zwerge doch das jetzt
entdeckte objekt ist anders entdeckt
wurde es von einem astronomie team aus
kalifornien
sie hatten es mit radioteleskope des
very large array beobachtet und gleich
festgestellt dass es für einen braunen
zwerg eigentlich zu klein und zu leicht
ist hier jetzt seine konkreten daten im
vergleich zum jupiter dem größten
planeten des sonnensystems das
mysteriöse objekt ist rund 12,7
jupitermassen schwer doch die grenze ab
der eine delhi um kernfusion möglich ist
und ein objekt als brauner zwerg
bezeichnet werden kann liegt bei 13
jupitermassen und so liegt das objekt
knapp darunter zudem ist das objekt auch
mit seinen 825 grad auch nicht heiß
genug für einen braunen zwerg das
forschungsteam schätzt den mysteriösen
himmelskörper auf jugendliche 200
millionen jahre
diese fakten lassen also eher darauf
schließen dass es sich um einen riesigen
planeten
infrage kommen unter diesen umständen
nur sogenannte einzelgänger planeten das
sind gasriesen die alleine durch das all
wandern und eben nicht um einen stern
kreisen bisher geht man davon aus dass
solche einzelgänger planeten entweder
ähnlich wie sterne entstanden sind
nämlich durch den kollaps von gaswolken
als eine andere möglichkeit ihrer
entstehung werden turbulenzen angesehen
die die objekte aus ihrem heimatplaneten
system ins all geschleudert haben zu all
diesen rätseln kommen zwei weitere
seltsame beobachtungen hinzu
der mysteriöse himmelskörper hat ein
gigantisches magnetfeld etwa 200 mal
stärker als das vom jupiter dazu
schreibt das forschungsteam aus
kalifornien zitat die kombination von
alter masse und temperatur dieses
himmelskörpers kann ein so starkes
magnetfeld nicht erklären
doch wie kommt es dann zu stande eine
vermutung ist nun dass das objekt eine
extrem schnelle rotation besitzt was
zudem weitere rätsel aufgibt der grenz
läufer hat auch polarlichter wie kann
das sein schließlich gibt es in seiner
nähe keine sterne und somit auch keine
sonnenwinde die diese leuchte
erscheinung durch eine interaktion mit
dem magnetfeld erklären könnten
eine erklärung könnte sein dass das
objekt einen planeten oder mond besitzt
der in wechselwirkung mit dem magnetfeld
des mysteriösen objekts polarlichter
auslöst ähnlich passiert dies beim
saturn und seinem mund m namens
enceladus vorstellbar wäre aber auch
dass die polarlichter durch
wechselwirkungen innerhalb der
atmosphäre des objekts entstehen so ist
es bei einigen polarlichtern des
jupiters der fall auf die große frage
planet oder brauner zwerg haben die
astronomie teams bisher keine eindeutige
antwort geben können
dennoch wurde das objekt bereits in eine
gruppe eingeordnet und zwar in die
spektral klasse c 2.5 darin befinden
sich braune riesen die in ihren
spektralen signaturen hinweise auf
methan was sagt kohlenmonoxid aber auch
natrium und kalium in ihren atmosphären
haben das forschungsteam aus kalifornien
ist sich sicher schon bald mehr über
dieses objekt zu wissen das könnte dann
wiederum dabei helfen die magnetischen
prozesse bei sternen und planeten besser
zu verstehen das sagt eine
beteiligten forscherinnen melodika ab
sofort könnt ihr auch bei pixum mitglied
werden für einen monatlichen betrag
bekommt ihr neben ein paar privilegien
ein extra video und einen extra live
stream nur für euch einfach hier unten
auf mitglied werden klicken und wenn er
kein video zum thema astronomie zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr
die etwas unzuverlässige abo box hier
auf youtube und werdet sogar vorab über
neue videos informiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren dafür
hier kriegen aber nicht die genau die
glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter
mit dafür auch draufklicken erste
aufzeichnung einer supernovaexplosion
bis dann bleibt dran